[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
chronique et de reportage sur public SC
à 90 minutes pour donner du sens à
l'actualité grâce à nos experts
qu'attendent les Français du projet de
loi immigration qui sera examiné à
partir de lundi prochain au Sénat c'est
le thème central de notre baromètre
politique d'octobre et c'est d'abord un
contrôle à cru qu'espère nos
compatriotes autre leçon du sondage la
percée confirmée de Gabriel Atal le
ministre de l'Éducation deuxème
personnalité préférée derrière Édouard
Philippe devant Marine Le Pen on
décortique toutes ces tendances dans une
minute et puis pour notre second débat
direction le proche orient 25e jour de
guerre et un benjamine netaniaahou qui
refuse d'envisager tous c le
feu tout comme les États-Unis n'ont pas
accepté de cesser le feu après le
bombardement de Perl Harbor ou après
l'attaque terroriste du 11 septembre
Israël n'acceptera pas de cesser les
hostilités avec le Hamas après les
horribles attaques du 7
octobre l'armée israélienne reconnaît
deux soldats tués aujourd'hui et parle
de combat féroce dans la bande de Gaza
le ramasse des comptes plus de 8500
morts depuis le 7 octobre c'est aussi
une guerre informationnelle que l'on va
analyser avec nos invités dans trois
quarts d'heure mais d'abord notre
baromètre odoxa mascaré pour Sénat et
les titres de la presse quotidienne
régionale avec un président de la
République qui voit sa côte de
popularité remonter un peu Samia de chia
les contextes de crise sont souvent
favorables au président en exercice dans
un mois d'octobre marqué par le conflit
entre Israël et le Hamas et l'assassinat
d'un professeur à haras Emmanuel Macron
remonte légèrement dans les sondages sa
code de popularité se is à 34 %
d'opinion favorable en progression de 2
points son ancien Premier ministre
Édouard Philippe reste en tête du
palmarès des personnalités politiques
suivi de près par Gabriel hatal le
ministre de l'Éducation gagne 4 points
dans l'opinion et passe devant Marine Le
Pen rétrogradé à la 3è place ce qu'on
attendait pas forcément c'est Gabriel
Atal qui a fait une très très bonne je
dirais rentrée au ministère de de
l'éducation national les les les ses
premières actions ses premières prises
de parole lui ont été profitabl lui ont
donné une stature d'homme d'État c'est
très intéressant de voir apparaître
comme ça ce ce ce ce challenger
finalement de d'Édouard Philippe et ça
veut dire que dans cet espace du centre
il va y avoir une compétition serrée et
pendant que la côe de popularité de
Gabriel Attal déécole celle de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon est en chute libre il est
désormais la personnalité politique la
plus rejetée des Français avec 62 %
d'opinions défavorables une place
qu'occupait encore Éric Zemour le mois
dernier Jean-Luc Mélenchon il devient un
populaire pour au moins trois raisons la
première c'est que les affaires quatnin
Chikirou n'ont pas été gérés il a fait
un j'assume très macroniste ensuite il y
a eu le la stratégie parlementaire
totalement illisible brouillonne et puis
il y a ses prises de position
extrêmement étrange y compris pour sa
propre base sur le conflit
israélo-palestinien Jean-Luc Mélenchon
recule aussi parmi les sympathisants de
gauche et d'extrême gauche et doit
désormais partager la tête d'affiche
avec le communiste Fabien Rousel chez
les sympathisants de droite et d'extrême
droite Marine Le Pen perd aussi 4 points
mais elle reste première devant Jordane
Bardella et Marion maréchal signe d'un
réel glissement de l'électorat de droite
vers le rassemblement national et on
tire les leçon de ce baromètre politique
du mois d'octobre avec G Sliman bonsoir
bienvenue le président et cofondateur
d'odoxa Anne Charl Bina bonsoir
bienvenue constitutionnaliste et maître
de conférence en droit public Richard
verl bonsoir bienvenue à vous
correspondant fr France Europe pour le
média Suisse blique on est également en
duplexe avec Yv Sany Seigneur partenire
chez mascaré vous scrutez les réseaux
sociaux pour notre baromètre bonsoir à
vous et laéticia crupa bonsoir laticia
bienvenue électoraliste politique on va
pour repler des personnalité plus tard
dans notre débat mais on va commencer
par peut-être la remontée tiens des
thèmes sécuritaires dans les
préoccupations des Français Gael Sliman
on peut dire que le contraire aurait été
surprenant vu le contexte quells sont
les les les les données de de votre
baromètre de notre baromère ce qui est
intéressant Thomas c'est qu'on peut
chiffrer les choses avec ce baromètre si
on si on aurait pu deviner que les
thématiques de sécurité de lutte contre
le terrorisme allait monter en flèche et
d'immigration accessoirement aussi de
combien et en l'occurrence ce qu'on
observe c'est qu'on voit la sécurité la
lutte contre le terrorisme bondir de 13
points par rapport au à à à nos toutes
récentes dernières mesures avant ces
épisodes tragiques et surtout devenir ou
redevenir l'alpha et l'oméga des
attentes de l'électorat de droite et des
extrême droite des sympathisants LR
jusqu'au sympathisants RN quand vous
avez parlé sécurité lutte contre le
terrorisme et immigration vous avez
souvent le cœur de leur priorité ça veut
dire que là on voit on voit pardon de de
vous interrompre le le le le le pouvoir
d'achat à la santé reste en tête hein
des préoccupations des Français mais
quand on on scrute l'électorat de droite
c'est un peu différent alors c'est
intéressant parce que contre toute
attente pour les sympathisants LR
finalement plus encore que pour les
sympathisants RN ces thématique de
sécurité de lutte contre le terrorisme
et les thématiques aussi d'immigration
sont très largement plébiscité sur
l'immigration par exemple on est à 53 %
de citations pour les sympathisants LR
et on est à 62 pour les sympathisants du
RN donc pour les sympathisants LR il n'y
a guerre que une autre thématique proche
celle de de la sécurité enfin classique
pour la droite qui arrive devant pour
les sympathisants RN il y a quand même
une autre notion qui est la notion du
pouvoir d'achat qui reste très présente
mais l'immigration pousse très très fort
euh on est à a plus 16 points pour les
sympathisants du RN sur le sujet par
exemple an Charline
bizina on vient de le voir avec Gael
plus 6 points pour le thème de
l'immigration euh ça reste quand même
loin derrière le pouvoir d'achat ou la
santé pourquoi le gouvernement en fait
un thème peut-être le thème majeur de
cette rentrée parlementaire d'après je
pense que c'est un des thèmes où c'est
le plus facile d'être entendu au niveau
des résultats à partir du moment où vous
annoncez que vous allez faire quelque
chose il y a une capacité de réassurance
qui est possible sur ce thème-là euh qui
est moins sur les thèmes du pouvoir
d'achat ou la la le le le social le
portefeuille hein c'était ce que disait
le Général de GA d'ailleurs c'est
vraiment là qu'on mesure une élection
très vite c'est que il y a besoin de
résultats beaucoup plus immédiats
chiffrés et sur l'immigration c'est plus
simple de de faire des déclarations si
bien qu'on se rend compte que je crois
que sous notre 5e République avec les
lois pénales les lois antiterroristes et
les lois d'immigration sont les lois qui
reviennent le plus souvent presque tous
les ans ou les 18 mois les 2 ans euh
puisque on peut les colorer
politiquement les teinter aussi des
faits d' non c'est on est un peu dans ce
qu'on appelle les lois du 20ingur euh
parce que il y a il y a cet effet tout
de suite de voilà de qui suscite
l'adhésion de l'opinion donc je crois
vraiment que c'est c'est un petit peu ça
et puis vous le disiez sécurité et
immigration c'est un binôme qui à la
fois va bien ensemble et à la fois est
porteur de beaucoup de contradictions
c'est-à-dire que quand on veut de la
sécurité on a ce cette tendance au repli
et donc la loi d'immigration elle doit
pas non plus suivre tout de suite cette
attente là sous peine de de de recréer
un petit peu cette cette p tion autour
de l'immigration donc il y a il y a
aussi beaucoup d'écueil à éviter et puis
on verra que c'est une forme de piège
pour le le gouvernement ça on en parlera
un petit peu plus tard Richard ver quand
on entend une personnalité politique
prononcer le mot immigration tout le
monde ou presque entend Islam oui
effectivement est est-ce que ça traverse
un peu toutes les sociétés occidentales
en ce moment oui alors c'est un élément
que j'aais rajoutter à ce que dit an
Charlen c'est c'est bien évidemment le
contexte international il y avait quand
même eu un moment de flottement à la
rentrée sur cette sur ce projet de loi
immigration Emmanuel Macron
s'interrogait est-ce qu'on aurait un
référendum est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'il y
aurait dans cette loi et puis d'un seul
coup tout le monde est revenu à la
charge à la faveur du contexte
international d'abord parce qu'il y a eu
un certain nombre de problèmes
migratoires Lampedusa vous vous souvenez
mais ensuite maintenant le conflit à
Gaza et l'hypothèse d'abord de d'une
menace terroriste et éventuellement
d'une menace migratoire ou de flux
migratoire qui pourrait être consécutif
à ce qui se passe en ce moment au Proche
Orient donc moi je suis pas du tout
étonné alors vous dites association
immigration Islam évidemment c'est comme
ça que c'est entendu ou en tout cas
c'est comme ça que c'est perçu après là
où peut-être j'auris un élément de
divergence c'est que pour moi on est
vraiment d'abord sur le terrain de la
communication parce que l'empilement oui
alors l'empilement des lois sur
l'immigration pardonnez-moi mais si ça
avait fonctionné il y aurait des
résultats or le problème c'est qu'il y a
pas eu de résultats le problème c'est
qu'on voit bien que sur le terrain de
l'immigration les gouvernements ont sans
cesse été je dirais soit n'ont pas pris
les bonnes mesures soit non pas les
moyens d'appliquer les mesures qu'ils
prennent toujours est-il que c'est quand
même pour moi vu de l'étranger un
constat d'échec que de revenir
maintenant à nouveau avec une loi alors
qu'il y a déjà énormément d'instruments
législatifs mais les instruments que le
gouvernement n'est pas toujours capable
d'utiliser compte tenu du nombre de
recours ou des difficultés administratif
notamment pour les les les octf les
obligations en vous écoutant il me vient
quelque chose assez évident et immédiat
c'est aussi l'angle mort d'Emmanuel
Macron depuis 2017 c'est-à-dire que
toutes les oppositions lui reprochent
sans cesse depuis qu'il est àé
que son angle mort est la sécurité et le
régalien et l'immigration donc c'est
assez logique et d'ailleurs il avait
fait plusieurs effets d'annonces
rappelez-vous cette grande interview
dans valeur actuelle qui a fait beaucoup
beaucoup parler ça fait longtemps qu'on
attend Emmanuel Macron sur le sujet donc
c'est normal qu'il arrive oui alors
c'est intéressant oui effectivement
c'est intéressant ce que dit richichard
Verly sur le le effectivement le manque
d'efficacité on va dire ça comme ça de
l'empilement des lois malgré ça galsiman
il y a encore une attente des français
qu'on qu'on voit très bien à travers
notre re baromètre vous avez notamment
son des Français sur les deux objectifs
le contrôle et l'intégration et ça c'est
intéressant de voir ce qui ce qu'il
répondent à la question selon vous
lequel des deux objectifs du projet de
la immigration est le plus important
qu'est-ce qu'ils nous disent les ils
nous disent que c'est mieux contrôler
l'immigration bien davantage que
d'améliorer l'intégration des immigrés
ou on les a interrogé en leur demandant
de choisir entre les deux hein si on
leur avait demander est-ce que chacun
est important il aura probablement dit
oui mais on voit que la priorité
aujourd'hui perçu c'est cette idée
d'améliorer le contrôle de l'immigration
bien davantage que l'idée d'améliorer
l'intégration et dans le en même temps
d'Emmanuel Macron y compris sur ce
projet de loi il y a des dispositions et
on va en parler qui prévoi aussi une
meilleure intégration de des des
étrangers qui travaillent notamment euh
et cette disposition là n'est pas ce qui
intéresse le plus les gens d'ailleurs on
verra qu'ils sont plutôt d'accord he
mais ce qui les intéresse c'est de mieux
contrôler cette immigration juste je je
reviens d'un mot sur ce que disait Anne
Charlen qui est tout à fait juste je
pense sur l' l'objectif poursuivi par
Emmanuel Macron est-ce que vous avez dit
les uns et les autres mais il y a
quelque chose qui m'étonne toujours
c'est que sur cette thématique de
l'immigration si on veut
jouer du cynisme politique ou sur la
réale politique bah jusqu'à présent à
chaque fois que des gouvernements du
centre centre droit ou centre gauche ont
voulu aller sur cette thématique de
l'immigration et d'ailleurs c'est la
même chose sur la sécurité c'est un
petit peu comme si en foot on préférait
jouer à l'extérieur ça signifie que
tout ce que vous pourrez dire et
proposer sera décodé plutôt négativement
et que vous décalez plus encore le
prisme de l'intérêt des gens des
Français sur cette thématique de
l'immigration où par principe on estime
que ceux qui ont préempté le territoire
c'est la droite et surtout l'extrême
droite c'est comme si vous donniez des
points jusqu'à présent ça s'est toujours
passé comme ça donc ça veut dire si on
est de gauche ou de centre gauche faut
mieux pas y aller quoi gr il vaut mieux
le faire mais de toute façon
l'immigration fait partie des des
domaines de la politique d'un
gouvernement donc on ne peut pas se dire
on va pas y aller il faut bien mener s
si ça fait déjà déà lo déjà des dizaines
de lois c'est peut-être pas la peine
mais en tout cas si on pense qu'il faut
faire quelque chose il faut le faire
mais si le but et je partage votre
sentiment et de faire de la comme sur ce
sujetl pour comme le disait latia
occuper un angle mort ou quelque chose
qui nous est reproché il est fort
probable que ça se retournera contre
vous parce que l'électorat très sensible
à ces questions à droite à l'extrême
droite et bien considérera vraiment que
vous n'en faites pas assez et les
électeurs de gauche qui quand on le voit
d'ailleurs dans dans les résultats de
l'enquête eux penchent plutôt pour
l'intégration des étrangers ils sont
dans la minorité qui pensent plutôt à ça
euh trouvera que vous menez une
politique droitière donc vous avez
toutes les chances de perdre sur tous
les tableaux alors peut-être que je
serai démenti dans les semaines ou les
mois qui viennent et qu'on verra que ça
lui a profité entre guillemets mais
jusqu'à présent ça ne se produit jamais
et donc il est fort probable que tout
cela se retourne contre lui autre
élément euh autre résultat du du
baromètre sur sur la priorité au au au
contrôle je vais donner là le le
résultat projet de loi immigration ce
texte propose-t-il des mesure efficace
pour et là aussi on a cette alternative
proposée au au au français mieux
contrôer l'immigration il y a un
optimiste on va dire un peu plus
important à 41 % améliorer l'intégration
des immigrés 22 % de oui seulement
j'ajoute que beaucoup de gens ne sont
pas au courant donc en fait là on est
sur la totalité des Français si on prend
ceux qui disent ils sont pas au courant
qu'il y aura une loi sur courant de des
dispositions de ce qu'il y a dedans
détail de ce qu'il y a dedans donc ce 41
% est juste mais si on exclut les 40 %
gros de gens qui disent mais de quoi me
parlez-vous j'ai jamais entendu parler
de cette histoire ou je ne connais pas
bien les dispositions ça fait quand même
les 2/ers de ceux qui sont au courant ou
pensent être au deans qui disent ça ce
sera efficace sur mie contrôler donc ils
ont le sentiment les Français que ce
sera plutôt efficace pour mieux
contrôler l'immigration et plutôt pas
efficace à 58 % pour mieux intégrer si
on se souvient du lancement du projet de
loi il y avait il y avait le ministre de
l'Intérieur et le ministre du du du
travail il y avait Géral haranin et
Olivier duop on a quand même beaucoup
plus entendu Gérald armanin depuis
depuis quelques mois bref Anne Charl
Bina ce ce projet de loi ce qui est
intéressant c'est
que on a le sentiment qu'il est d'abord
pensé pour favoriser des alliances
parlementaires alors en effet avant de
parler du fond presque c'est vrai que
quand on nous l'avait présenté parce
qu'on nous l'a présenté plusieurs fois
quand même ce projet de loi immigration
disons-le quand on l'a présenté
initialement avait le sentiment qu'il y
avait un petit peu la synthèse de la
macronie c'est-à-dire la fameuse jambe
de droite et de gauche le en même temps
qui était incarné par cette logique
d'immigration et de de questions
intérieures et pourtant on voit bien
qu'on est plus apte à perdre la jambe de
gauche vous avez parlé de la priorité de
Géral Darmanin sur la scène politique
c'est pas anodin parce que c'est là
qu'on va arriver à faire les alliances
donc oui cette loi immigration avant la
discussion budgétaire en tout cas en
même temps que cet autonne budgétaire
nous prouve qu'on est là en train de
vivre des échéances de cette majorité
relative à l'Assemblée nationale et on
est en train de tester la capacité de ce
gouvernement à savoir faire des
alliances sur sa droite parce que c'est
quand même ce qui a cruellement pêché
pour la réforme des retraite donc il y a
une manière de Sallier le groupe les
républicains qui est recherché par ce
gouvernement alors encore une fois avec
à mon avis une stratégie qui n'est pas
forcément payante qui consiste à lâcher
du l'est avant même la discussion au
Parlement alors que par exemple si vous
prenez l'alternative du gouvernement
Rocard et bien euh la tension était
encore très grande dans les débats
parlementaires parce que on maintenait
on va dire jusqu'au bout la ttention
pour avoir des tractations des choses à
laisser et cetera et c'est vrai qu'on a
le sentiment qu'on a un gouvernement qui
tâonne beaucoup qui cafouille aussi un
petit peu en terme de communication
politique puisque les uns ne sont pas
forcément d'accord avec les autres et
donc je crois qu'on n'est pas encore
complètement prêt à ce que ce
gouvernement crée des alliances un
dernier point sur ce terme de
l'immigration on a dit qu'on attendait
beaucoup Emmanuel Macron mais on oublie
souvent de porter à son bilan la loi
asile et immigration qui était la loi
Gérard Colomb qui avait été perçu quand
même comme une loi déjà très à droite
pour un ministre qui lui-même
voilà VO même Liberti puisquelle intègre
dans le code pénal beaucoup de choses
qui relevaient de l'état d'urgence
auparavant donc attention c'est pas
quand même son premier bilan un coup
d'œil du côté des des réseaux sociaux
des médias sociaux avec Yv Sani sur
cette thématique de de
l'immigration c'est quoi c'est lié au
fait divers en fait quand il y a un fait
divers ou pire un attentat un attentat
terroriste le thème remonte un peu
mécaniquement dans les dans les
conversations premier élément de la
question et puis de qui sont les
personnalités qui tirent leur épingle du
jeu sur ces thématiqu là celle qui
j'allais dire crie plus fort que les
autres est-ce que c'est ça écoutez sur
les réseaux sociaux quand disons que
quand on scrute les sujets de de
politique intérieure bien sûr on on on
va
euh on va pouvoir distinguer les
différentes positions des uns et des
autres mais euh le le conflit israëlopes
palestinien pardon a eu quand même une
un effet déflagratoire sur tout ça je
vais vous donner un exemple euh on a euh
à peu près 4 30 millions d'engagements
en seulement un mois sur sur ce sujet du
conflit on a 10000 10000 mention si on
fait une comparaison avec l'attentat
d'aras par
exemple comparé au 40 millions
d'engagements sur le conflit aras
c'était 1 million 8 million
d'engagements et simplement 1 million de
de de mention
donc cet effet de déflagration sur le
débat national cette importation du
conflit israëlo-palestinien sur débat
nationale avec toute sa dimension on va
dire émotionnelle et passionnelle
euh probable ne peut avoir qu'un effet
sur sur la question de l'immigration et
je reviens sur ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure
euh cette euh cet effet passionnel
extrêmement fort euh a un effet
forcément sur les questions sécuritaires
euh on évoquait ellisabeth borne même
elle en tant que Premier ministre a été
beaucoup plus entendu sur ces sujets que
sur les sujets de politique intérieure h
merci si revient vers vous tout à
l'heure peut-être une une question sur
ce ce piège que le gouvernement s'est
tendu lui-même Richard verli est-ce que
vous le définissez comme ça quand on
voit ce ce ce ce projet de loi
immigration avancer bon le piège on le
verra je dirais à la sortie à la sortie
du débat parlementaire on VO ce qu' en
sort moi je pense qu'il y a il y a deux
éléments d'abord il y a une équation on
n a pas encore parlé personnel Gérald
armanin il faut quand même le dire il y
a un jeu de Gérald armalin il y a une
posture liée à ses propres à son ses
ambitions à sa position de ministre de
l'Intérieur au à son passé au fait que
tout ça s'est passé quand je fais
référence à aras donc sur ces terres
électorales bref je crois qu'on peut pas
le dissocier est-ce que c'est un piège
moi je vois deux j'en voie deux des
pièges le premier je reviens sur le
terrain de l'efficacité c'est
démontrez-nous le gouvernement que ça va
être efficace moi j'ai lu tous les
éléments à ma disposition je ne suis pas
du tout convaincu que cette loi va
augmenter l'efficacité des dispositifs
or quelque chose qui n'est pas efficace
bah c'est le fameux millefeuille
législative français on y revient et ça
prouvera que c'est seulement de la com
le deuxième piège c'est celui
quiévoquait Gael Siman c'est qu'à force
de parler de ce thème de le mettre en
avant bien évidemment on fait le jeu du
discours de l'extrême droite et d'une
extrême droite qui pour l'instant elle
comme vous l'avez très bien dit parle de
pouvoir d'achat elle n'a pas besoin de
parler d'immigration puisqu'on sait que
c'est son thème donc elle apparaî Marine
Le Pen national apparî comme les seules
partis qui sont capables de parler
d'autres choses alors là c'est bingo on
reparlera des personnalités plus tard
mais peut-être un tout petit focus sur
Gérald armanin il est il est est-ce
qu'il tire profit de la séquence pas
tant que ça en fait non non et en fait
il y a toujours quelque chose de
troublant quand on est sondeur parce que
on parle des poids lourds politiques je
crois que je l'ai déjà dit sur ce
plateau mais on dit OUI parmi les poids
lourds politiques et on cite toujours
dans les médias Gérald armanin mais
j'avoue que on comprend pas pourquoi
vous dites ça parce que quand on regarde
ce que nous disent les gens dans les
sondages il a une code de popularité ou
d'adhésion moyenne voire médiocre il
compris auprès des gens de droite il a
une côe de rejet plutôt élevée pour vous
situer les choses il y a 26 % des gens
qui se disent en proximité en sympathie
en adésion avec lui 39 % des Français se
disent disent le rejeter et puis les
autres sont indifférents et ça ce de
notoiété justement B c'est le la
différence 26 39 et vous avez les autres
qui sont dans une bonne indifférence
avec lui donc autour d'un tiers des
Français mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est comparer aux autres on va parler
de Gabriel Atal tout à l'heure voilà là
c'est un poids lourd on peut parler de
Bruno Leem Bruno le c'est un poids lourd
quand on teste les gens que l'on
souhaite voir rester au gouvernement ou
partir à chaque fois qu'on a testé Géral
haranin les gens disaient mais qu'il
s'en aillent donc on a du mal à
comprendre en fait le poids qu'il occupe
à part son c'est pas du tout Sarkozy
2005 ah mais non ça n'a rien à voir
quand vous regardiez Sarkozi 2005 bah il
était une star politique il y avait des
gens qui le détestaient mais il il avait
une côte d'adhésion extrêmement forte il
était déjà favori pour 2007 il y a eu
des moments tangents avec ses goen royal
dans les enquêtes mais en tout cas
c'était un poids lourd vous aviez
Sarkozi Villepin là si vous cherchez des
poids lourds dans la macronie vous avez
àal vous avez le maire bon c'est à peu
près tout vous pouvez éventuellement
avoir verérant mais c'est vraiment loin
derrière
que en c'est pour ça que je je citais
pas lui compris bien compris numéro
allez on va continuer de parler du
contenu de de ce texte je propose à
Steve Jourdain de nous rejoindre sur ce
plateau on va parler notamment des
métiers en tension bonsoir St l'heure de
vérité approche puisque le début de
l'examen je l'ai dit c'est c'est lundi
prochain 6 novembre au Sénat et ce texte
pourrait tout simplement être rejeté oui
vous êtes devenu un spécialiste du
texte Thomas on va aller directement au
désaccords qui persiste entre le
gouvernement et le Sénat c'est
effectivement l'article 3 l'article 3
qui prévoit de délivrer de plein droit
une carte de séjour temporaire à un
étranger qui travaille pendant au moins
8 mois dans un un secteur en tension
cela concerne par exemple le secteur de
la restauration ou encore du bâtiment
pour les LR au Sénat hors de question de
voter un texte qui contiendrait une
telle mesure écoutez Bruno rotillon si
on régularise toujours plus comment
voulez-vous que on dise au français on
va adopter un texte ferme une des
conditions c'est d'arrêter des
régularisations massives tes que permet
aujourd'hui le fameux article 3 moi ce
que je veux c'est le moins possible de
régularisation ce que je veux c'est que
le fait de travailler ne donne pas droit
à régularisation parce que vous pouvez
avoir d'ailleurs des
islamistes qui travaillent moi ce que je
veux c'est que le préfet puisse par la
voie réglementaire se dire ok il
travaille ça se passe bien mais en même
temps il est ou elle
intégrable sur cet article 3 Le parti LR
veut prouver qu'il avance uni oui dans
les colonnes du JDD le patron des LR
menace tout simplement de faire tomber
le gouvernement éicti lance un ultimatum
si le gouvernement passe en force
notamment en imposant son article 3 qui
régularise les clandestins nous
n'hésiterons pas à déposer il manque un
r une motion de censure alors ça n'a pas
vraiment impressionné l'exécutif écoutez
Gérald dermanin c'était hier sur BFM TV
on veut intégrer les personnes il faut
qu'elle puisse travailler dans les
restaurants dans l'agriculture dans le
BTP vous savez quoi il y a plein
d'étrangers autant on doit expulser
l'étranger délinquant autant on doit
intégrer l'étranger qui
travaille un compromis entre le
gouvernement et les LR on en parle
depuis quoi des semaines euh ça semble
quand même compliqué d'autant que avec
le temps la droite elle a 1 curseurs un
peu plus la durci demand oua ouais ouais
27 article au départ la Commission des
loi euh du Sénat en a déjà ajouté 24
parmi les mesures demandées par la
droite on retrouve notamment la
transformation de l'Ame l'aide médicale
d'État en Amu aide médical d'urgence il
y a aussi un durcissement des conditions
du regroupement familial ou encore une
réforme de la procédure d'octroi de la
nationalité il y aura encore beaucoup
d'autres propositions promettent les
sénateurs LR certains évoquent une
vingtaine une vingtaine de nouveaux
articles qui pourrai être déposés la
semaine prochaine on va bien s'amuser
ici au Sénat à voir comment le
gouvernement accueillera ces nouvelles
demandes le salut du texte et un
éventuel compromis pourrait venir et
bien grâce au soutien de la gauche et du
groupe Union centriste qui est mené par
Hervé Marseille merci beaucoup Steve
jour un chall bu ça veut dire que c'est
pas totalement perdu il y a il y a des
tractations en cours qui sont d'ailleurs
très intéressante ici au Sénat avec St
vient de le dire le le le groupe
centriste bien sûr des
voilà des tractations qui existent
existeront sur il faut s'habituer un
petit peu à ce type de de Réal politique
vous en parliez tout à l'heure parce que
c'est la c'est la c'est la réalité d'une
majorité relative qui existe dans
beaucoup de régimes parlementaires ça ça
devient un petit peu la loi il y a de
moins en moins de majorité écrasante
comme ça qui se dégage dans les régimes
on a besoin de travailler les uns avec
les autres oui tractation c'est pas un
gros mot et c'est pas une magouille
voyez ce que je veux dire il faut
peut-être qu'on s'habitue à ce que ça
négocie autour du contenu d' projet
alors nous en France on est un peu
traumatisé parce que la dernière fois
qu'on a eu des tractations Parlement
c'est la 4e République c'est vrai que ça
nous avit pas tellement réussi donc on a
voulu consolider avec notre 5e mais bon
sur le terrain de l'immigration c'est
plus difficile quand même d'arriver à se
mettre d'accord parce que c'est
évidemment quelque chose de très
identitaire de très clivant
l'immigration la nationalité et encore
une fois on est aussi dans le sacroin
domaine où on oppose la politique au
droit donc on est toujours dans un
discours politique qui va consister à
dire que des entraves juridiques
existent pour avancer dans cette dans
cette voie et je je crois qu'il faut le
dire à l'intention de ceux qui nous
écoutent euh il y a évidemment des
limites qui existent qui sont celles des
conventions internationales Genève la
cour la convention et la Cour européenne
des droits de l'homme mais par exemple
le droit de l'Union européenne à part
sur quelques questions de partage
migratoire euh n'a pas beaucoup de
porter sur le terrain intérieur
antiterroriste que nous voulons
développer aujourd'hui par exemple donc
euh on entend beaucoup de choses mais
une vraie marge de choix politiques
nationaux existe a déjà été prise et l'
coup de lois terrorist c'est qu' réalité
viennent répéter sous une forme
différente des dispositifs qui existent
déjà donc je rejoins la politique de
l'efficacité et de l'efficience il faut
que ça marche il faut qu'on crée quelque
chose de nouveau cette fois-ci parce que
sans ça on va encore donner un petit peu
l'impression qu'on est entavé dans une
politique qui pourtant est tout à fait
libre Richard ver quand vous entendez
brunootillot le chef de fil des
sénateurs
LR on parle d'une question sur les
métiers en tenstion et très vite on est
métiers en tenstion immigration
terrorisme dans dans la même phrase
islamlamist Islam islamisme pardonam il
a pas dit terroristme mais céit mais je
l'ai entendu vous voyez c'est
intéressant islamisme euh c'est c'est
quoi comment vous l'analyser ça est-ce
que c'est une dérive de de la droite
parlementaire est-ce que voilà c'est à
force de voir Marine Le Pen caracoler
quasiment en tête des des des sondages
comment vous l'analysez oui je pense que
d'abord c'est une obsession c'està-dire
que c'est une obsession et c'est une
erreur l'obsession c'est celle de penser
que derrière tout musulman tout musulman
se cache potentiellement un islamiste et
derrière quelqu'un qui est pour un islam
fondamentaliste un terroriste et ça cet
amalgame il est fait pour toute une
partie du personnel politique français
notamment à droite et la partie la plus
délicate de l'amalgame la plus
problématique c'est quand même celle
entre musulmans et islamiste parce que
c'est de ça dont il s'agit ensuite quand
même une nuance à ce que disait Anne
Charlen et effectivement le droit
national permet encore aux pays membres
de l'Union européenne d'avoir une grande
je dirais autonomie dans leur politique
d'immigration sauf que on est dans un
espace Schengen de libre circulation ne
l'oublions juste pas c'estàdire qu'à
partir du moment où un étranger en
situation irrégulière et sur le
territoire de Schengen vous ne le
maîtrisez plus c'est tout le problème et
je le dis d'autant plus qu'un pays comme
la Suisse qui n'est pas membre de
l'Union européenne est membre de
l'espace Schengen et là il y a
effectivement une difficulté et moi ce
qui m'inquiète dans tout ça c'est qu'en
plus il y a une difficulté de calendrier
on va discuter en France d'une loi sur
l'immigration alors que à Bruxelles il y
a aussi la discussion entre le par
Parlement européen et le Conseil c'est
les étatsmembres du pacte asilemigration
et tout ça n'est pas vraiment coordonné
et par exemple sur la question des
retours je voudrais juste dire qui est
très importante le seul texte européen
qui est aujourd'hui en vigueur je parle
pas des textes qui ont été déposés et
qui sont discutés il date de 2008 c'est
vous dire que l'Union européenne sur ce
plan est vraiment en retard et là
question son des retours c'est au niveau
européen qu'elle doit être gérée parce
que c'est seulement l'Union européenne
qui a le levier sur les pays d'origine à
travers
lesig exactement
fa si vous avez x le le réseau x ancien
Twitter moi j'ai j'ai quitté Twitter
depuis que musk et le patron mais ça ne
regarde que moi bref Gérald Darman a un
tweet depuis plusieurs jours sur chaque
retour à la frontière c'est vraiment
inéress très intéressant à regarder tout
à fait g Sliman sur cette question des
des titre de séjour métier entention
vous avez évidemment sondé l'opinion
question a approuvez-vous la création
d'un tritre de séjour pour les métiers
en tension réponse des Français assez
partagé oui mais c'est quand même oui
c'est-à-dire que en plus c'est pas la
première fois qu'on pose la question on
l'a posé régulièrement dans le cadre de
de notre sondage d'actualité qu'on fait
chaque semaine avec le Figaro et
backbone Consulting on a on a posé ces
questions et à chaque fois on a une
nette majorité de Français quand même
voyez là c'est 55 la dernière fois on
était à 57 on a eu 58 on l'a posé à
plusieurs reprises et ce que je trouve
le plus intéressant c'est de regarder ce
que disent les sympathisants LR or ça
s'est dégradé la part de sympathisants
LR qui sont favorables à ce titre de
séjour MTI en tention mais c'est un sur
de la dernière fois quand on l'avait
testé on était à près de 60 % qui était
favorable ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que à travers cette posture ces prises
de position de LR sur ce sujet et
notamment le fait qu'il soit vent debout
contre cette disposition titre de séjour
métier en tenstion LR se positionne en
rupture par rapport à à Renaissance et
par rapport au gouvernement se
positionne peut- peut-être d'une façon
qui séduit ou qui satisfait sa base
militante et je distingue bien les
militants des sympathisants en revanche
une partie des sympathisants c'est des
gens qui peuvent voter pour vous des
électeurs potentiels de de ce parti bah
peuvent être un peu perturbés parce que
la ligne en même temps après avoir dit
que c'était assez dangereux d'aller sur
ce terrainl de l'immigration pour
Emmanuel Macron disons tout de même que
là encore à chaque fois qu'on a testé la
plupart des dispositions des idées qu'il
y avait derrière ce projet de loi bah
les Français dans leur ensemble ils sont
favorables à à la fois les mesures les
plus dures les mesures restrictives mais
aussi les mesures comme ce titre de
séjour m donc sensible à cet équilibre
l'idé de l'équilibre où ce qu'on
entendait dire Gérald armanin dans votre
extrait sur le fait d'être sévère ou dur
avec les illégaux les clandestins mais
de permettre à ceux qui essaient de
s'intégrer entre guillemets de qui
travaillent et bien de pouvoir vivre
correctement cette idée làà elle est
archi soutenue par l'opinion publique et
y compris par bon nombre de
sympathisants de droite h donc c'est
aussi le côté amusant de cette situation
si j'ose dire c'est que encore une fois
les seuls qui seront très à l'aise avec
leur électorat en plus ils ne disent
quasiment rien sur le sujet bah c'est au
rassemblement national on le dit rien on
ramasse la mise et on laisse les partis
qui sont plus à notre gauche c'est tripé
sur un sujet qui nous rapporte à nous
c'est formidable justement vous m'ofrez
la transition puisquon avait prévu tout
de suite un zoom sur Marine Le Pen je
propose de regarder d'abord le le
palmarès de l'adhésion du du baromètre
au doxa de de ce mois d'octobredard qui
reste en tête avec 40 % de de sympathie
Gabriel Atal on l'a évoqué qui progresse
plus 4 ensuite Marine Le Pen qui reste
sur le podium avec une légère baisse
Jordan Bardella son lieutenant juste
derrière Bruno leemire est à 28 % et
progresse les Laeticia la la chef de fil
des députés RN qui joue la carte de la
discrétion en tout cas il y a une
communication qui est pensée avec
précision objectif 2027 oui et
d'ailleurs vous l'avez très bien dit
Giman parce que c'est vraiment l'jet de
mon édito et vous avez tout à fait
raison Marine Le Pen elle a pas besoin
de communiquer beaucoup pourquoi parce
qu'elle a la marque RN qui lui sert
finalement de vitrime exceptionnel pour
les Français on sait tous ce que le RN
veut en matière d'immigration donc
Marine Le Pen parle peu mais elle
continue quand même Thomas de d'accepter
de répondre aux invitations de médiia
par par exemple dimanche là elle était
sur France 3 dans dimanche en politique
elle répond oui aux invitations quand
elle a quelque chose à dire voilà
dimanche elle nous a dit deux choses
elle nous a dit un je suis la principale
opposante à Emmanuel Macron parce que
parfois c'est vrai qu'on on hésite entre
elle et Jean-Luc Mélenchon là elle dit
c'est moi et vous allez voir aux
européennes les scores du rassemblement
national le prouveront et deux elle va
bien sûr sur cette loi immigration
puisque c'est du pain Méni pour elle en
disant c'est une petite loi insuffisante
le RN et le seul parti à proposé des
musies qui sont vraiment utiles dans
cette matière mais elle elle laisse
planer l'hypothèse de pouvoir voter
cette petite loi même si elle est
insuffisante elle surf aussi évidemment
sur la situation internationale en
tentant de tirer profit de la de la
guerre au Proche Orient oui et c'est une
stratégie cynique en de temps
c'est-à-dire que d'abord elle a laissé
la gauche se diviser sur le sujet du
Hamas sur l'appellation terroriste ou
pas enfin je vais pas tout vous refaire
elle a laissé la gauche se débrouiller
et elle a laissé aussi Jean-Luc
Mélenchon dans son UCE et dans cette
stratégie hein qui a été pensée de du
bruit et de la fureur partout et tout le
temps elle le laisse faire naufrage pour
dans un deuxème temps apparaître comme
la politique
sereine qui est capable elle de gérer la
situation et qui est ferme sur le
soutien à Israël et aussi sur la
condamnation de toute formme d'islamisme
donc finalement Thomas Marine Le Pen
poursuit sa stratégie de normalisation
et la parachève en tirant bien sûr
utilité de l'actualité internationale
mais elle fait toujours vraiment tout en
fonction de la position et faites bien
attention de Jean-Luc Mélenchon dès
qu'il est dans l'excès elle est dans la
réserve voilà c'est le calcul de Marine
Le de Marine Le Pen et alors elle
cherche aussi elle continue d'essayer de
de de de prendre aux autres partis des
personnalités qui pourraient permettre
de montrer que le relation ement
national est un parti de gouvernement
c'est l'objectif de la normalisation
dire on est un parti comme les autres
regardez un tel nous a rejoint un tel va
nous rejoindre et il y a eu un nom là
qui a apparu dans ces dernières semaines
le nom d'une prise de guerre on pourrait
dire
amincatmi qui qui est une figure du
printemps républicain et qui vient du
Parti socialiste alors il a démenti hein
depuis il a dit qu'il n avait aucune
tractation aucun dialogue mais le simple
fait de citer ce nom et que ce soit C
dans les médias donne au RN l'image d'un
élargissement idéologique et le présente
comme un parti attrape tout vous avez
tout à fait raison l'objectif c'est
encore une fois d'apparaître comme un
parti de gouvernement donc en clair
l'objectif c'est de casser
définitivement le cordon sanitaire qui
l'empêche finalement de de de passer
l'étape du du second tour et là elle
fait le Paris que ce sera la cordon
sanitaire qui s'appliquera à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon justement en 2027 route pas si
dégagé le principal danger pour venir de
l'intérieur oui puisque le RN est quand
même le parti avec les républicains bien
sûr mais le RN est le parti du culte du
chef or il se murmure que si Jordane
Bardella alors c'est un peu paradoxal
donc suivez bien si Jordane Bardella
fait d'excellents scores aux élection
européennes cela pourrait gêner Marine
Le Pen et ça deviendrait le premier
problème de Marine Le Pen pour 2027 on
suivra ça évidemment il y a le palmarès
de l'adhésion g Sliman et puis a celui
du rejet c'est toujours intéressant de
de comparer les deux parce que elle se
situe où Marine Le Pen dans ce palmarès
du rejet la pauvre elle recule elle
recule constamment sur le rejet depuis
depuis maintenant quelques années
pendant très longtemps elle était numéro
1 sur le par d'ailleurs c'était de père
en fille les Le Pen pre fille et quand
on testait Marion maréchal on l' retesté
cette fois-ci c'était pas très compliqué
on savait qu'on avait toujours un Le Pen
en haut du palmarès du rejet et puis
depuis la candidature d'Éric Zémour à la
présidentielle et bien l'accélération de
la diabolisation de Marine Le Pen s'est
opéré elle a reculé dans le palmarès du
rejet aujourd'hui elle est dans le top
10 du rejet mais par exemple elle se
situe en français la rejetant à la 7e
place elle est au niveau d'Eric Dupont
Moretti d'Eric soioti elle est loin loin
derrière le champion toute catégorie
maintenant du rejet qui est Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui a ravi la première place à
celui qui était toujours premier depuis
la présidentielle c'est-à-dire éc
Zemmour et évidemment que ce que vous
disiez sur la position de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon sur le conflit
israëlo-palestinien a été un facteur
déterminant parce que ça fait un moment
que Jean-Luc Mélenchon une partie de
l'opinion publique a du mal à le
supporter et qu'il trouble y compris ses
propres électeurs ou son propre camp de
de de la gauche de la gauche mais là ces
prises de position sur sur le Hamas ont
été complètement incomprises y compris
par sa propre base et ça explique cette
progression de Jean-Luc Mélenchon sur le
palmarès du rejet et le fait qu'il
prenne cette première place je pense
qu'il s'est la cranté quelque chose et
que ce sera très compliqué maintenant
pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon de revenir en
arrière il y était un peu parvenu après
le fameux la République c'est moi qui
avait déjà beaucoup surpris il y a
quelques il y a quelques années
maintenant et il avait quand même réussi
à remonter la pente pendant la campagne
la dernière présidentielle oui en
gommant les aspérités pendant la
campagne et puis vous savez vous êtes un
électeur de gauche à un moment donné
vous voyez une une adidalgo à 2 % vous
voulez voter pour quelqu'un de gauche
bah vous n'avez pas beaucoup le choix là
je pense que cette fois ce sera très
compliqué h pour des électeurs de gauche
qui ont été sensibilisés par cette ces
prises de position ser le candidat du
vote utile ce sera ce sera très
difficilement le candidat du vote utile
et et très certainement qu'il s'est mis
dans une position durablement
inconfortable dans l'opinion alors
n'oublions jamais il n reste plus de 3
ans voir 3 ans et demi donc on va rester
on va rester très très prudent par
rapport à tout ça mais si on se
s'intéresse à Charl ba sur le moment
présent et la stratégie de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon sondage après sondage on on on
voit que cette stratégie elle est
perdante dans opinion pourquoi il
s'enferment là-dedans moi j'ai du mal à
à comprendre ça est-ce qu'on peut pas
imaginer finalement que ça soit une
partie intégrante du personnage en tant
que tel parce que aujourd'hui il faut
pas oublier qu'on parle on est en train
de tester quelqu'un qui ne fait plus
partie officiellement de la vie
politique il a aucun mandat il est
uniquement là pour influencer au niveau
idéologique de langage et cetera et on
voit que ça fonctionne quand même encore
c'est-à-dire que même si il n'est pas
officiellement la voix parlante de LFI
et bien tout le monde ou en tout cas il
y a une espèce de discipline autour de
lui qui là s'est fissuré précisément
c'est-à-dire que sur ce conflitl les
positions ont été tellement radicales
que on a vu une famille un petit peu
chancelée mais je crois que la la
question du bruit et de la fureur alors
n'oublions pas quand même qu'on a ces
mouvements dit de populisme européen qui
qui revendique l'idée d'entrer dans les
assemblées et dans les cénacles
parlementaires notamment européens pour
détruire un système de l'intérieur mais
je crois que finalement ça c'est une
stratégie très pensée par des coalitions
pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon à mon avis ça me
semble vraiment faire partie d'une d'une
forme de manière de faire d'une manière
d'être il a il a claqué la porte de de
de plusieurs organisations avant de
créer la sienne donc je je crois
vraiment qu'il a été dépassé par par
lui-même à ce sujet et c'est
intéressant de exactement c'est ce que
je crois et et je crois que c'est
intéressant de voir que finalement même
dans des périodes identitaires très
fortes parce que on parle quand même du
regain de la sécurité de l'identité
nationale et cetera et bien même dans
ces périodes là finalement les Français
vont chercher
certes des discours politiques audibles
mais quand même de la mesure et voire
même une certaine forme d'unité
nationale n'oublions pas que nous sommes
un des peuple qui et je crois que
beaucoup d'entre nous réagissent comme
ça lorsqu'ils sont frappés à l'intérieur
ont quand même besoin d'entendre moins
de cris et de fureur justement pour
s'unir autour de de de de ce genre de Dr
allez on a commencé cette émission avec
le le sujet de Sam du chir
qui proposer un focus sur la popularité
du président de la République on va
terminer là-dessus je vous propose
peut-être de revoir une séquence récente
Emmanuel Macron de retour de sa visite
de 48 he au ProcheOrient qui fait un peu
le bilan de cette visite il est encore
sur le tarmac de l'aéroport du kaer j'ai
senti des dirigeants engagés très
inquiets pour leur région et avec
lesquel on va continuer de travailler
ils veulent le faire dans un certain
cadre de discrétion surtout pour les
questions les plus sécuritaires que je
veux respecter mon objectif ici c'était
d'essayer de de contribuer modestement
mais à stopper les escalade qui est en
cours la montée des tensions qui peut
avoir un caractère inéluctable et
ensuite irréversible extrêmement
dangereux
Emmanuel Macron qui progresse dans notre
baromètre plus de points avec 66 % de
non à la réponse Emmanuel Macron est-il
un bon Président de la République mais
34 % de oui Richard verli c'est assez
classique quand on est dans un dans un
contexte international on va dire
guerrier c'est on appelle ça la la la
l'effet drapeau c'est ça oui sûrement et
puis il y a aussi probablement le fait
que il agit il essae de faire quelque
chose euh alors on peut contester son
initiative sur la coalition
internationale contre le terrorisme mais
de fait il a été le seul des dirigeants
européens ils ont quand même été une
dizaine à se rendre à Jérusalem et bien
lui il a été le seul à formuler une
proposition aussi contestable soit-elle
aussi discutable et ensuite il a réussi
il faut bien le dire à aller non
seulement du côté de l'Autorité
palestinienne mais également en Jordanie
en Égypte donc il sa'est quand même je
dirais il a il a réussi une à être un
petit peu au-dessus des autres leaders
européens en terme d'effet diplomatique
ça ne veut pas dire que ça apportera des
résultats mais en tout cas la France est
là et sans doute que les Français ils
sont sensibles dernier mot Gael Sliman
est il est solide ce si on compare un
Emmanuel Macron peut-être à son premier
mandat au même moment ou c'est un socle
solide oui parce que on a on a testé
justement sa visite au ProcheOrient dans
d'autres enquêtes et il y avait une
petite fragil
une grosse fragilité sur Emmanuel Macron
sur l'international et un sentiment que
en fait il est assez en phase avec ce
que semble penser une très large
majorité de Français c'est-à-dire c'est
ce qui a coûté très cher à Jean-Luc
menchon c'est d'abord les atrocités
commises par le Hamas ont bouleverser
nos concitoyens ils en ont été très
choqués ils voulaient entendre des mots
forts ils voulaient entendre de la
solidarité il a porté cela et en même
temps comme dirait l'autre ou dans la
foulée là c'est Gaza qui est frappé ce
sont des des des des centainesou des des
milliers de civils de femmes d'enfants
qui sont tués et les Français ils sont
très sensibles aussi et il a tenu
Emmanuel Macron un discours devant
Benjamin netanahou qui était un discours
plutôt courageux et il a rappelé des
choses en rappelant l'objectif des deux
états en rappelant l'objectif des deux
états c'est parce qu'il y a de plus
simple à faire à ce moment-là en Israël
et il a tenu des discours qui pouvaient
ne pas être si simple non plus dans les
autres pays du Proche Orient et donc
cette position là pour l'avoir testé en
enquête elle plaît plutôt à nos
concitoyens et c'est ce que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon a raté parce que fondamental
le le ce qui ce qu'il a ce qu'il a tué
en quelque sorte dans dans dans nos
enquêtes dans notre baromètre c'est
cette incapacité à nommer les choses
correctement et notamment à appeler un
chat un chat un terroriste un terroriste
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat ici en plateau et et et en duplex
à bientôt évidemment sur sur Public
Sénat